pas qu'ils a également avisé encore à
l'heure des réformes promises
[Musique]
on sait les écoles les garderies sont
fermés vous êtes plusieurs à être
confinées à la maison avec les enfants
comment ça se passe on a demandé aux
enfants de nous l'expliquer vous allez
voir leurs réponses ont pas mal
pourquoi est-ce qu'on reste à la maison
a pris un micro en main par tlk
navarrais mais quoi pourquoi c'est
important de rester à la maison quand
même ce qu'on soit à la maison
nec moi parce que je préfère rester à
l'école ou ici c'est comment je fais
[Musique]
c'est pour les activités camper ici on
joue à cache cache
oui il est un fait et leur explique que
la peinture
fait des cahiers d'activités et j'avais
une partie de cet effet de la partie ne
fait pas
[Musique]
jet d'eau au fait des cabanes et c'est
beaucoup d'étudiants c'est aussi à moi
je n'ai jamais jamais de coupler des
fêtes
je joue d'or se rater oui oui est ce que
tu aimes sont un peu toiles aux rappels
automatiques l'automne pourquoi après
qui compte c'est ce que tu aimes
vraiment à l'état j'arrête
[Musique]
c'est pas vraiment non non toute manière
ça est sa conformité comme pour ben est
conçu comme à 6 ans à 14 geste à poser
des questions dit à ceux qui ne veulent
pas qu'il veuille quand ça y avait
besoin que sont la mise en pré vente met
[Musique]
ma main aux tétons mama il faut ça mille
et vas y j'espère que vous avez eu
autant plaisir que moi à regarder les
vidéos par les enfants si j'avais des
idées d'activités qui pourrait inspirer
dons par an faites nous en part dans les
commentaires
a+
[Musique]